pour analyser cette joute entre Ottawa
méta et Google on reçoit Colette brin et
les professeurs à l'université Laval
directrice du Centre d'études sur les
médias bonsoir madame alors donc mettons
avait ouvert les hostilités en premier
maintenant c'est Google qui retire les
liens du contenu médiatique canadien
est-ce que ça va s'arrêter là ou est-ce
qu'on peut s'attendre à d'autres
préseurs contre la loi C18 écouter je
pourrais pas vous le dire mais c'est
certain que le gouvernement anticipait
ce genre de mesure et que les
négociations étaient déjà prévues pour
cette étape alors il va falloir
qu'elle sera le rapport de force que
t'auras va réussir à établir avec ces
deux grandes plateformes qui sont très
puissantes qu'est-ce qu'elles espèrent
ces plateformes là ou juste est-ce que
est-ce que des compromis c'est
envisageables où elles veulent carrément
qu'on approche la loi ecoutez c'est sûr
que je pense que de leur point de vue
l'idéal serait que la loi soit abrogée
je pense pas que ça soit réaliste non
mais si on regarde ce qui s'est passé en
Australie en fait c'est que justement
cette pression là nous a permis
d'alléger ou d'assouplir les mesures qui
étaient prévues pour qu'elles soient
plus avantageuse notamment pour Facebook
mais dans le cas du Canada les mesures
sont déjà plus strictes que ce que
l'Australie avait anticipé il y a plus
de médias un plus grand nombre de médias
qui sont
admissibles si on veut à ses ententes là
et les exigences sont plus strictes pour
pour les plateformes donc c'est sûr que
le Canada n'est peut-être pas un grand
marché il n'est peut-être pas un grand
risque pour ces plateformes-là mais
c'est aussi un exemple pour d'autres
juridictions qui s'apprêtent les
chevérés dans le même sens dont laquelle
fournit c'est ça exactement et ce qu'on
comprend c'est que ce qu'on souhaiterait
faire même du côté de la Californie ce
sera encore plus sévère qu'au Canada là
je dois vous dire que je connais pas
tous les détails ce qui est intéressant
dans le cas de la Californie c'est bien
sûr que c'est leur lieu de résidence si
on veut au lieu d'origine de ces
plateformes là donc la Californie je
pense que ça va jouer tout très dur et
dans l'Union européenne aussi bien sûr
étant donné la taille du marché mais le
Canada est en quelque sorte un petit
joueur qu'on veut utiliser en exemple et
aussi le voisin le voisin du Nord qui
est tellement dépendant des plateformes
américaines et des médias américains au
détriment tout ça évidemment de les
Canadiens qui utilisent cette
information qu'on trouve sur les réseaux
sociaux ou détriment aussi des
entreprises médiatiques canadiennes qui
avaient des ententes qui sont
confidentielles évidemment avec méta
avec Google mais est-ce qu'on peut
compenser que des joueurs qui avaient
ces ententes comme La Presse Canadienne
comme les Coop les formations le globet
de mer
dans un pétrin au niveau financier
absolument c'est vraiment comme vous
dites on n'a pas les détails de ces
entente là mais c'est des c'est des
plateformes qui sont essentielles on
peut bien dire que les médias
préféreraient s'en passer tous les
moyens en fait pour tous les points
d'accès pour l'information sont
essentielles que ce soit les moteurs de
recherche d'abord Google et les
plateformes de médias sociaux dont
Facebook est vraiment la plus populaire
les données qu'on recueille année après
année nous montre que les médias sociaux
sont une source d'information pour la
majorité des gens pas nécessairement la
source principale ni une source
importante dans le sens que les gens
vont s'informer de manière un peu au
hasard l'information va nous arriver sur
cette façon facile
on peut trouver cette même information
ailleurs est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on
exagère le pouvoir de ces plateformes
alors c'est des plateformes qui génèrent
énormément de trafic quand on cherche
quelque chose quand il se passe quelque
chose dans le monde puis on veut savoir
ce qui se passe on peut faire une
recherche Google Google Actualités
Google News alors c'est c'est là qu'on
va avoir toutes les sources à aller sur
une plateforme il faut être un peu
fidèle déjà sur une application d'un
média faut être déjà un peu fidèle faut
faire un effort peut-être de en fait de
télécharger cette application là d'aller
la consulter mais peut-être que ces
mesures-là vont amener les gens à
réfléchir à leurs épisode un peu comme
le sacré utilisable qu'on apporte à
l'épicerie là ça peut aller même jusqu'à
des revenus d'abonnement par exemple
parce qu'en ce moment il y a très peu de
Canadiens qui paient pour avoir à
l'accès à des plateformes privilégiées
avec un média ou plusieurs d'entre eux
est-ce que ces entreprises de presse
pourraient compter sur une certaine
fidélité par la suite je pense que c'est
disons qu'il faudra pas miser que
là-dessus c'est en fait ça fait partie
des des éléments de la campagne des
médias notamment les médias écrits qui
comptent beaucoup sur les abonnements
qui font qui font appel justement aux
abonnements dans cette période où on
sent vraiment la crise mais bon on est à
la fin juin on est à au début des
vacances c'est pas la période où les
gens sont nécessairement les plus les
plus attentifs à l'actualité alors j'ai
l'impression que il va falloir peut-être
quelques mois aller avant de voir
vraiment ce que tout ça va donner ouais
en tout cas ça va se jouer ça dans les
six prochains mois jusqu'à ce que c'est
18 en 30 milliards madame brun merci
beaucoup d'être venu en studio avec
plaisir pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]